Jeff sorry Beck is senior staff writer
for the athletic he covers the Ravens
and he's located in Baltimore he joins
us this morning Jeff thanks for joining
us I'm curious was anybody surprised
that John Harbaugh made the
pronouncement that hey Lamar Jackson is
our starting quarterback no I don't
think it was anybody was surprised you
could see that with the direction this
was headed for the last couple weeks
they've completely transformed their
offense under Lamar Jackson just in the
way they do things and it was gonna be
tough to go back to the other way you
know they become a run oriented
possession offense and they've built
some momentum here at a time where
they're pretty much must-win territory
the rest of the way going back to the
playoffs so while it was a it was a big
development just considering how long
Flacco was here and he's been the
starting quarterback for 11 years now I
don't think it was a surprising one okay
the difference in this team is you know
obviously this style with Lamar and Joe
Flacco as we get closer to the playoffs
and I playoff berths are they a better
team with Lamar Jackson come playoff
time or Joe Flacco in your opinion I
think they're better with Lamar Jackson
and you know everyone wants to talk
about the future or about how this style
isn't sustainable and you know what they
may be right but this isn't really about
that right now this is a franchise that
wants to get back to the playoffs that
needs to get back to playoffs that
hasn't been there for you know since
2014 and and you have a lot of people in
this building with jobs on the line they
need to win now I think they feel like
Lamar Jackson gives them the best chance
just because of the way they're doing
things they're controlling possession
they're you know keeping some pressure
off that defense which is one of the
better team that's in the league and is
not all that doesn't have to be on the
field too much and and he's provided a
spark he's got a new energy and they're
running the ball they weren't able to
run the ball nine weeks with Flacco so I
think they feel like this style gives
them the best chance to win games and
get to the playoffs and maybe have some
success there but we see teams later in
the season certainly in the postseason
they try to take away
you do well can Lamar Jackson succeed as
a passing quarterback yeah that's gonna
be the thing and you know a little more
Jackson story so far you have to mention
the fact that they played for the worst
Russian defenses in the league and
they've been able to line it up and and
kind of ram it down on other team
throats with their run game and can you
do that to the Chargers I don't know I
know the bangles had some success but
they're gonna need him to improve as a
passer they're gonna need to do some
different things to get a little more
creative to open some stuff up down the
field because their downfield passing
game is pretty much been non-existent
since Jackson took over so no I think
they're gonna need to do a lot more
offensively I think he's going to need
to show a lot more with his arm for them
to have a nice run but we you know
defense good special teams and a good
running game often plays this time of
year so I think he gives them a chance
but there's gonna have to be some
improvements made there Joe Flacco's
future is what yeah it's hard to see him
coming back next year now it's it's it
would be foolish right now to write him
off the rest of this season you know
Lamar Jackson has missed I missed the
last two games he's averaging 17 you
know carries a game so it's gonna be put
him as susceptible to injury and I think
we all know sports nobody would be
shocked if there's a story with Joe
Flacco coming onto the field when he's
next three weeks and having to make a
big drive to try to get them in a
playoff I mean that would be a just kind
of a story and and and we all know those
kind of things sort of tend to happen so
I don't think you can write him off this
year but you know I think it's pretty
clear that this is the direction they're
going with Lamar Jackson and Flacco
almost certainly be looking for a new
team coming off season do you believe
John Harbaugh was or is coaching for his
future there I think he is yeah you know
and they It's Made about what owner
Steve bisciotti
wants and and you know I'm gonna do when
I was well commented helped her last
season he said that he almost fired John
Harbaugh last if they missed the
playoffs for the third straight year if
they do a fourth straight year would be
hard to imagine Harbaugh keep his job
but
others you know kind of play with and I
mean you have an e/m coming in you have
a new quarterback right now you have a
roster with guys like Suggs Weddell you
know Jimmy Smith imposable E these guys
whether it's free agency retirement or
you know just sour attack casualties
some of these guys won't be back so this
is kind of a new team gonna be a new
team going forward and and you know
that's why I sort of explain to the head
coach and make sense it sort of fits
there but I do think you know this team
has played well on horrifies clearly so
he's one of the better coaches in the
league and if they go on a playoff run
here it's gonna be awfully hard for
Sally to make that decision to go in
another direction
good stuff Jeff we appreciate your time
good luck with the athletic thank you
thanks for having me have a great day
that's Jeff rebec he is with the
Atlantic he covers the Ravens for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]